j'augmente mes pneus ici a dit non
j'habite à gillot impossible talent au
travail est impossible d'aller sur la
libye investit le pourquoi pas sera sur
la route par tous ces coûts avaient
c'est une panne de trop pour cette
habitante de la cité dit long la goutte
d'eau qui fait déborder le vase car
circuler dans le quartier est devenu un
parcours du combattant pour les
automobilistes le passage incessant des
poids lourds a sérieusement abîmé les
routes partout c'est d'être où nous
vivons dans une cuillère encore soit
menthe et il me voilà la station pour
vous appeler mes pneus pourquoi vapeur à
dinan y accorder trop
les riverains craignent pour leur
sécurité et dénonce les nuisances
sonores d'un camion qui passe au cours
de la nuit la journée ça ne cessent tous
les jours tous les jours tous les jours
même le week-end les bâtiments ils
tombent
oui on n'en peut plus ce sont plus de
nids de poule ce sont des cratères moi
comme je cours je peux me garer
contourner mais si un petit jeune à qui
arrive à moto quand il pleut on ne voit
forcément pas les choses donc ça va
créer un drame total vont aux blessés
ça va il y aura des dégâts donc pour des
raisons de sécurité pour faire le
nécessaire
la municipalité de fort de france a pris
un arrêté pour interdire la circulation
des semi remorques et des camions à
toupie a cité dit long mais visiblement
il n'est pas respecté
les habitants réclament des travaux pour
améliorer l'état des routes et en plus
ce samedi une pas de carnaval
si les gens vont courir pour ne pas ça
fait rouler la javie j'espère qu'une
bouchée avant samedi
le problème s'était déjà posé l'an
dernier les habitants de volga plage
était monté au créneau pour empêcher le
passage des camions dans leurs quartiers
provoquée par le chantier de rénovation
de la rn9 depuis les transporteurs se
sont rabattus sur dix longs malgré
l'interdiction municipale